[Music]
we got Meghan Trainor's reaction to her
good friend ariana grande surprise
engagement have you talked to her since
she got engaged I haven't I saw her at
Wango Tango but I didn't have the ring
on in the performance I saw that and my
mom texted me like y'all I want to talk
about this but I'm so happy for them the
cutest thing of all time Ariana's 3
carat diamond engagement ring may have
impressed the poor's Meghan Trainor
but it was our mommy to be so heat
releases growing belly that had host
Ferg well hosting the for Fergie has
been balancing work and being a single
mom she says ex Josh Duhamel has helped
make it work yeah we split it up really
balanced and just so he gets a good
balance and we're all love and we love
each other and I have a good
co-parenting partner we work it out and
DJ Khaled's partnering up again with his
buddy Justin Beiber Khaled speaking of
top secret alert you posted with Justin
Bieber yes my brother I'm working on my
new wild father deciding and me and
Justin Bieber
we definitely got something in the works
but as the four team heads toward the
end of season two will there be a season
three we're halfway through the season
now so halftime I gotta ask already
season three I believe this one be a
season three but you know we gotta see
what what Fox feels to be honest
[Music]